we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is a
very unusual voicemail and this i don't
know if this is the same quote voice
actor who has called before they
actually sound a lot like someone who
calls in or does characters on the
Howard Stern Show with some advice about
why I shouldn't bite my fingernails
which I don't do take a listen to this
dude I want to share a parable with you
in the team on why you ought to bite
your fingernails you see when I was a
little boy like you and producer Pat I
bit my nails all the time awesome do
plain xiety and hyperactivity and
eventually I had to go to the doctor for
corrective surgery on my teachers due to
the damage I've done and when I got home
my mother said I could have a special
treat because I was in a bad mood you
see and she who I feel better after it's
like whole wheat toast with cream cheese
well sure enough in the fridge there was
a new tin of cream cheese waiting for me
but when I tried to open it up I
couldn't do it of all those wrappings on
the tips of my digits and despite my
efforts I couldn't get to the sweet
sweet cream cheese inside yes my bad
habit of nail fighting kept me from
being able to put my toast with sweet
sweet cream cheese oh and just let that
be a lesson to you you do yeah there is
something oddly captivating about that
now it does raise more questions than it
answers like for example is that a voice
actor or what are they talking about why
do people think I bite my fingernails
because I don't it's nothing that I've
ever ever ever done I just I don't
that's not a problem I have I'm not
aware if that's a problem producer Pat
has but it's certainly not one that I've
noticed but there are so many questions
I have about that and maybe someday some
of them will be answered but one of the
primary questions is who thinks to call
into a political show with a message
like that that is really the the primary
question that I have and I would love to
know the answer to it we've got a great
bonus show for you today a Donald Trump
is now vowing to release a report on his
finances before the 2020 election and
this is again a red herring and I'll
explain why on the bonus show Kamala
Harris is also apologizing for her
response after backlash
she was slurred and
her response upset the disability
community and I'll tell you about it and
much more on today's bonus show two ways
to get access become a member at join
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show